[Music]  hey yo [ __ ] want to get weird  [Applause]  and to how you do it back there dick  you know I normally don't call you all  about - [ __ ] this is a big deal I get it  this whole nother ballgame whoa you hear  about the murders huh someone drop this  guy off honey our murder murder yes we  got carried away last night no dude what  they doing Pulp Fiction Carl Anthony  Kiedis everything I'm Harvey Keitel  inking keys to do for my hospital yeah I  mean for like I mean not really I mean  yeah but like just for like a little  while  I left early you can't come home the SS  hit the fan what excuse me please lady  it's dead take is short for Richard oh  he fell on table saw he got shot by a  hunter alcohol port  [Music]  how did he die Zeke  tell me the truth and my secret love's  no secret anymore  are you joking  [Music]  [Music]